- [Narrator] Let's now continue
with our super fast journey
through history.
And one thing I want to point out,
because I already touched
on it in the previous video,
is while we talk about
this ancient history,
I'm also referring to some
stories from the Old Testament.
So let's call that religion.
Now, the reason why
I'm doing it is because
religion is such a big
part of our modern culture,
it's clearly, especially
the Old Testament,
is the basis of three major
world religions today,
and so it can help us hopefully
create a little bit more
of a narrative in our head on
some of these ancient events,
because a lot of these events
described in the Old Testament
have a historical context.
There was a Babylon, there
was a Neo-Babylonian Empire.
We're gonna talk about
Nebuchadnezzar in this video.
There were pharaohs,
these things are described
in the Old Testament.
Now, there's other things
in the Old Testament
that have less of a historical context,
where we really don't have evidence yet
of did they happen, or
did they happen in the way
that is described in the Old Testament?
We might be able to find
that evidence over time.
And then there's clearly a lot of events
that are not described
in the Old Testament,
but we are able to find evidence,
we're able to find documents,
writing, hieroglyphs,
we're able to find artifacts
and date those artifacts,
we're able to find ruins.
And the fun of history is
to try to figure out, well,
what do we know and what do we not know,
and can we construct
narratives that make sense?
And over time, whether
we're talking about events
that are referred to in the Old Testament,
or things where there's a
large historical basis for it,
as we understand more, these
dots might change a little bit,
or at least our understanding
of how they occurred
or the causality.
So that's one of the really
fun things in history,
and I encourage you, everything
that you hear me say,
don't take it for granted,
look it up yourself,
and come to your own conclusions.
So with that said, let's continue,
and I'll review a little
bit from the previous video.
We're in 1700 B.C..
It's the time of Hammurabi,
you have the code of Hammurabi,
famous, famous, as a written code,
a written code of laws.
Now, we believe, if
the stories of Abraham,
because there are parallels
between the Old Testament
and the code of Hammurabi,
it has often placed Abraham,
as a biblical figure,
is often placed in or shortly
after the time of Hammurabi.
And so it's Abraham of Ur,
and this migration to Canaan,
which would eventually become
the kingdom of Judea and Israel,
modern-day where the states
of Israel and Palestine are,
that migration, people place
it at around 1200, or sorry,
at around 1700 B.C.E.,
once again, roughly in
the time of Hammurabi.
Now, we don't know this.
There is not a lot of
historical evidence here,
but it fits kind of
the historical context,
especially with the code,
with the code of Hammurabi.
Now, we fast forward a few hundred years,
and now we're firmly on
the side of religion,
where these are stories
from the Old Testament.
We haven't found a lot of
historical evidence yet
of the migration of the
Jewish people to Egypt,
the famous story of Joseph.
So that's the migration, which is placed,
tends to be placed around 1500 B.C.E..
1500 B.C.E.,
and once again, I'm gonna
put a question mark here.
And so when we look at our timeline,
this is Abraham going from Mesopotamia
and then to what is now,
or to establish this tribe
in what eventually becomes Judea, Israel.
They're there for several hundred years,
you have the story of
Joseph, Abraham's grandson,
he becomes a vizier of the pharaoh,
his family eventually joins him,
but then the Jewish people get enslaved,
according to the Old Testament,
for several hundred years,
until they are freed
in the Book of Exodus by Moses,
and they are led back to Judea.
And so this part right over
here, we are definitely,
let me circle that in a color you can see.
This part right over here,
we're definitely operating outside of
a lot of historical evidence.
But we believe that the exodus
from Egypt back to Judea,
this is often placed around 1200 B.C.E..
So I know my map is
getting a little bit...
1200 B.C.E., and once again,
I'm gonna put a question mark there,
because we don't really know.
But that's where we believe that the,
what was essentially the
tribe of Jewish people
is now established as a real
state, as a real kingdom,
the united kingdom of Israel and Judea,
and you have the famous
kings, King Saul, King David,
King Solomon, King
Solomon famously noted for
the construction of the
first temple at Jerusalem.
And now we're gonna fast forward,
because in a few hundred years,
that temple gets destroyed
by the Neo-Babylonian Empire.
So let's fast forward a little bit.
The Neo-Babylonian Empire,
led by Nebuchadnezzar II,
often known as the Chaldean Empire.
This is approximately,
and I'm going very high
level in this video,
600 B.C.E., before the common era,
secular way of saying
before the time of Christ,
before Christ, you might often see B.C.,
which would refer to before Christ,
B.C.E. is referring to
before the common era,
but 600 B.C.E. and 600 B.C.
are referring to the same date.
But you have the Neo-Babylonian Empire,
and I'll stress the word Neo,
because even though you
hear a lot about Babylon
when we talk about ancient Mesopotamia,
you notice that Babylon was only dominant
for relatively short periods of time
when we look at this, you know,
multi-thousand year view of things.
Actually, most of the
time, in this period,
the Assyrians were dominant,
with their capital at Nineveh.
But when we get to roughly 600 B.C.E.,
you have Nebuchadnezzar II.
He is the king, the emperor,
of this Neo-Babylonian Empire,
and he goes...
He searches for conquest.
He wants to expand his empire.
And he's really set on
taking over the pharaohs,
among other people, or the Egyptians,
but on his way, he's unsuccessful
on taking over the pharaohs, so let me,
this is him on the way to try
to take over the pharaohs.
He is unsuccessful to
try to take over Egypt.
But on the way, he's able
to march through a lot of
what we now call the Middle East,
and relevant to the Old Testament,
he destroys the first
temple that Solomon built,
so he destroys that temple,
and then he takes the
Jewish people captive,
according to the Old Testament.
And that is the famous
Babylonian captivity,
and that was Nebuchadnezzar who does it.
Now, Nebuchadnezzar's empire, his dynasty,
is relatively short-lived in
the whole scheme of things.
The Neo-Babylonian Empire,
the Chaldean Empire,
because by the time we get to the,
or we get a little bit further
into the sixth century B.C.E.,
so around 539,
539 B.C.E., this is when
you have the Persians
come and invade the Neo-Babylonian Empire.
The Persians, led by Cyrus the Great.
So now you have the
Persians come and take over
the Neo-Babylonian Empire,
and on our timeline here,
this is the Persians going on,
going and taking over
more and more territory,
they take over Mesopotamia,
they're able to take
over what we, you know,
Judea and actually this whole region
that is kind of the modern Middle East,
and they are successful.
And this is a big deal,
because look how long this line
of Egyptian civilization is.
They are able to take over Egypt,
and they keep going their conquest,
and as we'll see in the next video,
they get very frustrated
because they're not able
to take over the Greeks,
even though in a lot of ways,
the Greeks did not seem as
significant of an empire
as the Egyptians or the Babylonians.
But we will continue
that in the next video.